Thinking about the 2 x 2 matrix on the last slide, a real question for you is--
how does your product get to the customer?
I think the real questions start with what type of product do I have.
Do I have a product made out of bits that is--is it virtual or is my product a physical product.
Now, I think that's a simple choice you need to make right now.
Is your product physical or is it bits.
The next thing you need to ask is what's going to be my distribution channel.
Is it going to be direct--that is am I going to either offer it on a website AOL
or have direct sales people that work for me, or is it to be indirect.
That is, am I going to put it on a third party website like an Amazon or a web aggregator,
or physically, am I going to use system integrators or VARs
or some other indirect channel like a retail store.
Just select what you think will work for your product, and so later on in the lecture,
we'll analyze the potential choices for you to pick for your product.